(band music climaxes)
(audience cheering)
- They're very excited.
- [Dwayne] Yeah.
- [Kelly] They're very excited.
- Look at this.
- Yes.
- Look at this group.
- [Audience Member] I love you!
- I love you, I love you too.
(Dwayne and Kelly laughing)
- When you go to like
Target, does that happen?
Do people just start cheering
(laughs) everywhere you go?
- Well, that's why I don't go to Target,
unfortunately.
- Okay, oh my god,
you're missing out.
- [Dwayne] I know, dude, I know.
- It's like one of my favorite places.
- I used to love going
to Walmart at like, midnight.
- Yeah, yeah, me too.
- Until I just couldn't do it anymore.
- Yeah, I was gonna say, you
can't really go incognito.
- I used to try and hide.
Right, but it used to be-
- Really?
- Well, like I'd wear like
a fisherman's hat low,
and it used to be like,
is that The Rock with a dumb hat?
(audience laughs)
And I would be trying to hide,
but...
- I feel like you can't hide.
- I cannot hide.
- Yep.
- That went out the window, so...
- Yeah, I was just like,
wow, that's amazing,
do you just get that everywhere you go?
That's amazing.
So you requested that song-
- I demand it, by the way.
- I was like, have your people scream.